oh sure oh hey guys how's it going my
name is markiplier and thanks so much
for stopping by and oh I'm wearing the
wrong shirt okay there we go okay so
I've got a special announcement there's
another charity livestream happening
this Saturday and you guys know that
I've been in LA for a long time I've
been doing a lot of videos there but
there was this one thing that I'm really
happy about that I managed to get done I
worked out a deal with Rodeo arcade to
make this shirt and you may be saying
like oh it's a normal shirt you've seen
it before but no it's got this very
special little detail here that was xyx
rising ly hard to put on but it's got a
little heart pixelated hard on the
sleeve that says markiplier is Heroes
and these shirts are going to be sold
one day only on the day of the
livestream and for every shirt sold
they're a little bit pricier than my
normal shirts so they're 25 instead of
22 but for every shirt sold 15 dollars
goes straight to the charity and a lot
of you been asking for like shirts to go
towards donation and I've made it so
that the most amount of money possible
out of each shirt go straight to
donation so if you've seen these before
these are really great shirts um they're
very comfortable I'm wearing a size
medium right now it fits very well it's
pretty long which I like the design is
very nicely made as you can probably see
it's not flaking it actually seems like
it's part of shirts oh and same with
this on the on the sleeve there that's
really nice lace is done you can
actually see the details of this tiny
text here so if you want to be a hero
please buy this shirt on Saturday when
it's available it's only available one
day um you get to wear your heart on
your sleeve and tell everyone what you
did and how you supported the cause I
don't know what charity we're gonna do
yet by we'll announce that the day
before so that you guys know going into
it and I will announce the second that
these shirts become available I'm hoping
to sell a thousand I don't know that may
seem like a lot but I've got over a
hundred thousand subscribers I think
that we can manage that so sincerely
thank you guys for your support
I'm really happy and thank you rodeo
arcade for making this for me and
working out this deal so I look forward
to this weekend okay in other news
yesterday I was supposed to post this
video because I want to start doing Vee
logs every week so that I can keep in
touch with you guys and really let you
guys know what's going on in my life
because there's been a lot of stuff
that's been happening with me going to
LA and me making about I don't know 20
to 30 videos I don't even know how many
but a lot of stuff is gonna be coming
out in the near future and I'm really
excited about that but one of them came
out yesterday which was another hot
pepper game review if you don't know
what that is it's where I ate a habanero
pepper and I cried like a little baby
and try to review games and I've
reviewed rogue legacy and amnesia a
machine for pigs which is the one that
came out yesterday so if you haven't
seen it yet click here ish here I want
to say they'll be some here somewhere
over here click there and you'll be
taken to video it's really funny I'm in
misery but apparently it's hilarious so
give them support it's a great Channel I
really love those guys to do it it's
really funny
in other news a lot of the videos that I
did in LA are gonna be coming out very
soon I mean some I did with Jesse Cox
that are probably some of the funniest
I've seen in a long time maybe that's
just me personally but I had a lot of
fun recording it we're gonna be coming
out in the next week or so and I will
let you guys know when they do um also
I'm gonna be trying to do a lot more
collabs with other guys you may have
seen already just as soon as I got back
I did something with captain sparkles
and yamimash captain sparkles I met
while I was in LA and I talked to him
quite a bit and he's a really cool guy
yamimash of courses giant do [ __ ] I had
oh I love yamimash and he's totally cool
and I'm hoping to do more with him and
gonna be collaborating with more people
in the future so just stay tuned for
that speaking of YouTube there's been
another problem with subscription feeds
um they haven't been updating and this
is like something stupid on youtubes
part I don't know why they did this but
if you go to your subscription feed and
you click on manage subscriptions you'll
see all your subscriptions there and
there will be check boxes that say
notify me when they upload and I go if
you're subscribing to a channel you want
to be notified when they
video but now you have to do it manually
for some reason so if you're having
problems do that it's a simple fix but I
don't know why YouTube didn't do it in
the first place so since the subscriber
feed isn't working it's actually been
negatively affecting my channel I've
been talking to other youtubers at the
same time and until YouTube sorts this
out we literally haven't been able to
get the videos up to more people and
people that are already subscribed to
our Channel it's really Cillian and I
don't know when YouTube's gonna sort it
out but in the meantime I really need
you guys's help I'm gonna rely on you to
spread the word about the channel and
share the videos around and I know you
guys do a great job at it I wouldn't be
where I am today if you weren't some of
the most supportive people on YouTube
the best community that I've seen so far
so sincerely thank you guys for doing
that but while this is happening if you
could just go out take your favorite
video find a friend who might like the
video tie him to a chair ball gag um oh
well don't do that but I mean if you
seriously got a friend that may like the
channel or may like some of the videos
that we do or wants to see more of the
gaming commentary the charity
livestreams or the other stuff or maybe
sketch comedy or or some random video
that I do that they may like please
share the video tell a friend about it
today it'll really go a long way to help
out and and seriously it'll help the
channel grow tremendously which it
already has I mean we're we're kind of I
looked at the statistics today we're
kind of on track to hit a million
subscribers by October 31st which would
be really crazy because that's Halloween
if you didn't know uh so that's about it
thank you guys sincerely so much for
watching I'll try to get these via logs
out to you every Monday I don't care if
you call them vlogs I call them V logs
they will be coming out on a regular
basis because I want to keep you guys in
the loop on stuff that's going on with
my channel and my life so thanks again
everybody for watching and I'll see you
next video bye-bye